pft pm yesterday shereen williams and i
looked at the nfc teams that both have
gotten work done
during the off season so far and then
nfc teams that still have work to do
miles and i are going to look at the afc
teams first that have taken care of
business so far this off season and i
see your picks and i am stunned i am
flabbergasted
by your first selection i would have
never guessed it
you never at all yeah i can only wonder
why you wouldn't have but no i think
that the browns have done a really good
job this offseason of taking care of
what they've needed to take care of they
needed to improve their defense they've
gone out they signed somebody in john
johnson who i thought was definitely one
of the top defensive free agents
available and it's partially because
he's coming off of his first contract
he's not somebody really that the rams
would want to get rid of it's just that
you know when you're paying somebody
like aaron donald and jalen ramsey and
then you decide that you want to pay
leonard floyd too you can't afford
everybody under the salary cap
especially in a depressed year like this
one so he goes to cleveland and i think
he's a really good fit for what
cleveland wants to do in the secondary
really good cerebral player and they
also sign somebody like troy hill also
used to be on the los angeles ramps i
think that's a good fit opposite denzel
award now the one thing i think that
they still can do is improve their pass
rush and they've done some of that maybe
by signing tech mckinley i don't know
how much you can really uh count on him
going into the 2021 season same thing
almost with gideon clowney and of course
got reported yesterday and was on the
transaction wire that he visited with
the browns as well but i just think from
the standpoint of
taking care of your needs by
supplementing guys and you're not
necessarily counting on them to be the
guys because the guys on defense in
cleveland are denzel ward and miles
garrett i think they've supplemented
them very well and so that's why i think
the browns had a great off season
by the way shereen has texted she has
requested clarification she is only
three months older than me so points
i'm glad she's surrendered yeah yeah
good good because that was that was just
very wrong the way you did that on the
way to break
it well and it was on the way to break
and i can't be held responsible for
anything i say on the way to break
because they're counting me while i'm
talking so words come out of my mouth
that i can't quite control so sorry
shireen who is only three months older
than me um i agree with you on the
browns i was intrigued by the jude
jadavian clowny visit who knows where
that's going to go i think clowney if
healthy
can be
an incredibly dominant force and i think
it's easy to get seduced by watching his
film of when he's healthy and forget
that you're not going to see that
jadavian clowney very often if he's on
your team i'm going to go with the
patriots just because
i'm fascinated by the fact that they
have broken so dramatically from
character when owner robert kraft tells
peter king we used to laugh at the teams
that spent in free agency and we're
aware of that they are very self-aware
that they are finally doing the thing
that they always made fun of it's like
hey we made fun of the guy who got a
perm and now we went out and got a perm
and that's okay because we got a reason
for going out and getting a perm but
they do have a reason for their roster
stinks and they willed that team to
seven and nine and they've gone out and
they've bought and they've bought and
they bought now i like what they've done
because i think they were very strategic
about what they offered i think they did
a lot of work before the negotiating
window opened surprise surprise teams
violate that standard all the time and i
think that they made it clear to the
agents for the players that they signed
this is what it's going to be and if you
don't take it i don't know what else
you're going to get you know what else
is out there we know what else is out
there you better take what we're
offering or you're going to be screwed
and it worked they lined up guy after
guy after guy after guy they've
addressed weaknesses on both sides of
the ball and i think it makes the afc
east a fascinating division this year
because the patriots have gotten better
and you rarely say that about the teams
that spend aggressively in free agency
but the patriots have never done it
before they've done it this year and i
think it's going to make them better
it should definitely make them better
and the other thing is i think that they
have not put themselves in a situation
where they can't improve at quarterback
because i've said this on this program
before and i still really think it that
they're probably going to have to make
some other move at qb um because of cam
newton and just the way that he wasn't
necessarily as good as you would want
him to be as a thrower last year so i'll
go to my second team and that would be
the chargers i love what the chargers
have done so far in free agency and
really it comes down almost just one
player that's signing corey linsley and
i think that that is a terrific signing
because to me there's almost nothing
more that or better that you can do for
a young quarterback than to give him a
veteran center who really knows what
he's doing because when you're a
quarterback there's so much that you
have to pay attention to at the line of
scrimmage you have to make all these
different calls you have to know what
the protections are if a veteran center
can take some of that off of the qb then
that makes it so much easier for the qb
to know what's going on in front of him
and then make the reads beyond what's in
front of him to those wide receivers and
those tight ends and running backs too
they're also in the eligible so i love
that signing i think it's terrific and i
think that it sets up the chargers very
well and also even though they lost
hunter henry they brought in a guy like
jared cook and he was down in new
orleans with now offensive coordinator
joe lombardi so he has the advantage of
being familiar with what that offensive
scheme is probably going to be i think
that the charger should be able to
continue justin herbert's good
progression and because of what they've
done in free agency mike
the biggest thing the chargers need to
do is figure out why it is they have so
many guys who get injured i think at
some point it's not just bad luck it is
training it's stretching its nutrition
it's something and if brandon staley the
new head coach can get that figured out
and keep this team healthy they can be
very very competitive the other afc team
for me i i'm con i'm conflicted on this
as we've established i'm conflicted on
many things
the jaguars i think may have spent
recklessly and foolishly and and maybe
not responsibly
but you know what when you're so bad and
you've got the money you may as well
because it's not like you're going to
get worse and trevor lawrence is on the
way so they genuinely believe that these
guys that they're adding are going to be
better and urban meyer has his built-in
excuse that he
didn't get a chance to do his proper due
diligence he complained last week about
the free agency process in the nfl so if
these guys stink he can say hey i didn't
get a chance to vet them the way i would
have but they did rely heavily on
relationships that their assistant
coaches have with the players that they
brought in and they're hopeful that
they've made good moves but when you've
got one of the worst teams in the nfl
it can't get much worse and i got to
give the jaguars credit for being
aggressive to try to turn around a team
that that has made as dramatic a fall as
i can remember a team making from being
an afc finalist and having that game won
against new england patriots to
basically collapsing into a heap of
nothing to the point where they've
earned the number one overall pick
they've never had in all these years the
first overall pick in the draft now they
have miles
well the other thing i mean that i think
of another team that was you know also
really good in the houston texans and
they're pretty darn close to making that
same sort of dramatic fall up 24-0 on
the chiefs in the divisional round last
year but i i think that it's really
interesting when you look at all the
moves that they made and you have to
think of them with trevor lawrence in
mind and is trevor lawrence going to be
able to get the most out of somebody
like a marvin jones we're not really too
sure yet but i think that they at least
have set themselves up to have a chance
and actually before this segment ends
mike there's something you said you're
talking about the patriots that i want
to circle back to
did you have a perm at one point because
it sounded like you were talking from
experience
did i do what now
did you have a perm
oh no no no i thought you asked me if i
had a pun no i never had a perm i never
had a perm you sure i i'm so old i
forgot that i even mentioned the word
perm no there is no visual evidence
anywhere trust me mullet yes
perm no i own the mullet i i deny ever
having a perm
vehemently aggressively shouting from
the rooftops i never had nor will i ever
have i don't care how stylish it becomes
they could pass a law that is required
that every human being have a perm i
would shave my head and say my hair fell
out all right let's take a break the afc
teams that need to do more
in the 2021 offseason perm free edition
of pftpm returns right after this
all right we talked about afc teams that
have taken care of business in the off
season that we are still smack dab in
the middle of afc teams now that still
have more work to do miles you're up
first as usual
all right well i'm gonna have to say the
ravens and i think it's because of what
they have failed to do so far at wide
receiver it's interesting i mean eric
dicasa talked about this before the
start of free agency that he wasn't
necessarily concerned
about being able to attract free agent
receivers to a team that was not only
32nd and passing yards but 32nd and
passing attempts so it's not like they
were really trying to throw the ball all
that much and when you have such a good
running offense you probably don't need
to but when you are trying to get a top
guy or at least somebody who can help
your passing attack
it might not behoove you to have the
kind of offense and the kind of
offensive scheme that they've had in the
last couple years so it seems like right
now they've struck out on juju smith
schuster they definitely struck out on
ty hilton he confirmed that earlier
today on the pat mcafee show so what are
they really going to be able to do to
improve it wide receiver it almost seems
like they're gonna have to draft
somebody i mean sammy watkins visited
with them he left without a deal and i
like some of the things that the ravens
have done this offseason for sure i like
the zeitler siding i think that the
signing i should say i think that fits
well with what they want to do in terms
of running the ball derrick wolfe coming
back bowser coming back pronounced feet
coming back oh that's good too but until
you actually address a wide receiver
position or maybe you even could go out
and decide another tight end because
that might fit a little bit better
i just i don't know exactly what they're
gonna do to make that offense as
good as it needs to be in order to
really evolve it because right now
everybody knows that it's hard for them
to throw the ball and they don't even
want to do it so if they don't have a
wide receiver and they don't get that
top guy
it's going to be tougher than next year
i think
i i i believe that the ravens are
trying their damnedest to
to talk their way away from the idea
that the team isn't attractive to free
agent receivers the reality is it's not
attractive to free agent receivers
that's not an indictment or margin
accident it's an indictment of the
offense the way the offense is
constructed you're not going to have the
ball thrown your way and if we know
anything about receivers it is they want
the ball to be thrown their way they
want to show what they can do they like
catching passes they don't like blocking
they don't like running routes and being
decoys they like having the football
thrown in their direction so they can
make things happen and if you have
choices if you give me the choice
between team
that will throw me the football and team
that won't throw me the football
i'm more likely to go to the team that
will it's that simple right first one
for me is the chiefs and
i understand they're the ones who chose
to move on from eric fisher and mitchell
schwartz we saw what happened without
those two in the super bowl the problem
is what have they really done to replace
them joe tooney is not a tackle he's
going to be playing guard unless they
move into a position that maybe he's not
comfortable playing they tried to get
trent williams and they failed they
tried to get juju smith schuster and
they failed they tried to get josh
reynolds and they failed you've got
patrick mahomes directly involved in
these efforts now maybe it's more
persuasive once the money has flowed and
once it's no longer about i'll get more
money somewhere else but to the extent
that the chiefs thought they were going
to convince people to take less to come
join the kansas city bandwagon
hasn't worked
and i i think that that
it's a cause for concern and is some of
the shine off of the kansas city chiefs
organization after the loss in the super
bowl i don't know i'm just alarmed by
the fact that this is a team that has
been trying to go out and make itself
better and it has failed
to do so and
they may be fine they may be back in the
super bowl this year they may win it
again but they definitely still have
work to do as they try to improve their
offensive line put patrick mahomes in a
better position and not have to run for
his life and address other deficiencies
on the team especially with sammy
watkins a free agent and possibly headed
somewhere else
i if they were able to sign trent
williams i think we would probably feel
dramatically different but as you just
said they failed to do it so when you do
fail to acquire that big left tackle
that you know you need especially after
the way you just got rid of eric fisher
then yeah i think it is some cause for
concern because patrick mahomes is
definitely gonna need somebody to block
form at least if they are even to try to
make it back to another super bowl um
but this i'm gonna change the rules of
the game because you usually do this all
the time and it's not necessarily just
teams that have more work to do it's
kind of like what are they doing i'm
gonna go with the raiders because what
exactly are they doing and i i just i
feel this way with the signing of kenyan
drake for as much guaranteed money as he
got i feel this way with not just
trading rodney hudson that
you know sometimes things happen with
veterans and you want to move on
but when you then sign andre james to a
contract extension when he's only
started one game for you in 2019 and
he's gonna be a restricted free agent
next year
i'm just not really understanding what
the logic is there i know that you want
to get better on the offensive line or
at least get cheaper and you feel like
andre james is not that much of a drop
off but you probably don't have enough
evidence that he's actually going to go
out there and be the kind of quality
player that you wanted to be and then
they signed martin from the texans and
then they it's been reported that
there's going to be some sort of
competition there between those two guys
for center what what's going on so i
don't really know what's going on there
i mean john brown should be a decent
signing especially for what they're
paying him but i also almost think that
he's a little bit very similar to henry
ruggs and if you really want to get
henry ruggs to where he should be as you
know the 13th overall pick in the draft
last year and what exactly are the roles
going to be there's a lot that the
raiders still have to figure out so it's
i guess it's still they have work to do
but it's also what's going on there mike
well
and and you know when you look at the
offensive line 60 turnover there and
there's this vague argument that john
gruden has a plan he knows what he's
doing well i assume he's had a plan in
the last three years how's that worked
out look
this is a guy who has not faced any real
scrutiny for the fact that he has been a
mediocre at best coach since winning the
super bowl 18 years ago and his return
to coaching for the past three years has
been a failure if the ultimate pass fail
is are you a playoff team and even with
seven teams per conference he couldn't
get in and if he doesn't make it this
year i don't know when mark davis holds
him accountable mark davis may just be
happy that john gruden is the head coach
regardless of what the team does davis
is used to having a bad team you can
either have a bad team that isn't
coached by john gruden or you can have a
bad team that is coached by john gruden
he'll take that every day of the week
but i i
look i remember when gruden signed the
10-year 100 million contract everybody
thought it was fully guaranteed and
everybody was like wow this is unreal
i my understanding is it's back loaded
and a lot of the stuff on the back end
isn't guaranteed we'll see as we get
closer and closer to maybe that aspect
of the deal whether or not there is real
accountability for john gruden and my
point is if it was anybody else any
other circumstance you'd at least be on
the hot seat going into this year and
maybe he is maybe he isn't we'll find
out i think the jets have more work to
do primarily because this quarterback
question has not been answered and they
will answer it they will do the work
they will check the box they just need
to get it right are they going to keep
sam darnold corey davis seem to think
that although why are they going to tell
their
strategy to corey davis the guy who just
signed with the team and let him blab
during a press conference but they need
to get this right at quarterback this
isn't just they need a quarterback they
need to know who it is they need to get
it right they need to evaluate the guys
who are going to be available with the
second overall pick and they better get
it right is zach wilson as good as chris
sims thinks the jets need to make that
decision they better get it right they
better get their other decisions right
with the draft picks they have the draft
pick they picked up from seattle for
jamal adams they got to start hitting on
these picks they got to continue to
build that team from the inside out and
they got to hope they can be competitive
because look at that division they're in
now it's not quite the nfc west not
quite the afc north but the bills are
great the patriots are the patriots the
dolphins are better the jets could be
left in the dust if they don't make some
good decisions over the balance of the
off-season miles
yeah they absolutely could be left in
the dust and so that's why i think
whether it's zach wilson or somebody
else whoever they figure out is the
solution at qb
like you just said they better get it
right and they better be gung-ho and
everybody's got to be pulling in the
same direction for it
all right let's go ahead and take a
break gives us some time to answer some
of your questions looks like some good
ones have made it through twitter today
we'll answer those
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports